du camping municipal de
saint-mars-la-pile il ne reste que cet
ancien panneau depuis le mois d'avril le
lieu est désormais une aire d'accueil
pour les campings caristes Sylvain et
Christine viennent de passer la nuit sur
place dans moins d'une heure il
prendront la direction de Beauval hier
midi en arrivant ils ont tout de même
pris le temps de découvrir les commerces
du village où ils font étape
on fait partie des camping-caristes qui
voulont faire marcher l'économie locale
et en faisant nos courses en allant au
restaurant Café
vraiment participer voir un petit peu ce
qui se passe sur la commune où on
s'arrête
à cause de ces frais fixes l'ancien
camping municipal n'était plus rentable
pas question pour autant de ne plus
accueillir les touristes de passage à
saint-mars-la-pile désormais grâce à une
convention passée avec une entreprise
spécialisée la collectivité loue son
terrain 1600 euros à l'année et reçoit
une participation pour chaque entrée une
façon habile de ne pas laisser filer ses
potentiels consommateurs
nous sommes en gros à 580 cartes nuitées
depuis trois mois ce qui veut dire
potentiellement généralement ces par
couple donc on est à peu près un peu
plus de 1000 personnes donc qui sont
passés sur notre commune donc autant de
consommation enfin voilà de personnes
qui consomment locales et qui consomment
sur la commune
selon le baromètre du tourisme en
camping-car pour la saison 2023 un
couple dépenserait en moyenne 44 euros
par jour en sortie ou nourriture un
apport économique non négligeable pour
la commune qui sait les recevoir
et le musée c'est les commerçants les
artisans locaux
le boulanger le charcutier le
restaurateur se fait venir avec son
camping-car plein rempli le frigidaire
c'est absolument faux nous en tout cas
c'est c'est pas du tout qu'on constate
sur sur les aires du réseau en 2022 près
de 91.000 camping-cars ont été
immatriculés en France un marché qui
s'élargit également au Vannes et fourgon
aménagés un tourisme itinérant qui a
pour destination principale la France et
ses régions
[Musique]